I remember the numbers crooked I think
that we were targeting like a trillion
and a half dollar deficit going into the
year or that was kind of the the general
thought then once you get all the
stimulus now it's like oh we might get
three and a half to four trillion if
they do more stimulus that could run up
as you said to six or seven trillion
dollars one of the big questions is just
like is it actually debt if you don't
have a plan or an intention to pay it
off like how do you think about that
deficit and in the national debt well
that's one of the weird things I mean
the so you have two sides of a balance
sheet here and in a healthy normal
economy the private sectors balance
sheet is always growing so the assets
are always growing and the liabilities
are growing there's nothing inherently
bad about debt in and of itself I mean
if you're if you're out there borrowing
and you're investing it in things that
are productive and innovative and you
know really useful sources of production
then there's nothing inherently wrong
with creating debt to do that
I think the the thing that people tend
to sort of generalize about is that
things like like a high credit card debt
is a revolving type of debt like that is
is terrible in the long run because it's
just it suffocates you there's no way
anybody can invent anything really that
or is certainly an aggregate that is
going to be able to consistently pay off
like a 20 percent credit card bill so I
think a lot of consumers have it in
their mind that that debt is always bad
and the reality is that a lot of debt is
actually very productive that a lot of
debt is used for good purposes and it
helps create the assets that make the
whole economy basically functioning and
sustainable in the long run I mean
though the whole reason the dollar is
the reserve currencies because for the
most part you do have businesses and US
consumers and households have been
incredibly innovative and productive
over the you know the history of the
United States and so we've used money in
a very innovative and resourceful way
that has created
the most output of any country in the
entire global economy ever and so that's
the main reason why the the dollar is
the reserve currency and it's why
there's so much demand for dollars
especially in times like right now
because it's it's backed by you know 25
trillion dollars of output that is
relatively safe compared to everybody
else's resources and so it's all it's
all kind of intertwined in this in this
sort of complex way and what's weird
about what the government does that is
so different from what the private
sector does is that the government debt
also grows in aggregate over time you
look at the like a trend of like
household debt it never goes down really
in the long run it should always go up I
mean how also debt should basically
always go up because the the households
assets will also go up in the long run
so in the long run the economy's total
financial assets and total financial
liabilities will basically be
ever-increasing the big kicker with the
difference between the private sector
debt and government debt is that private
sector debt can sort of be creatively
destroyed at times like during the
financial crisis you had a lot of you
basically had a big debt boom so he had
this sort of big real estate inflation
and in the reactor because in two large
do graffiti banks created too much money
it chased too few homes you had this big
boom but then the kicker is that thing
deflates over time that doesn't always
happen with the government because the
government oftentimes isn't actually
allowing any sort of market mechanism
there's no competitive force that forces
the government to like pay down in steps
over time so that's why this is such a
weird environment in my mind is because
the government is basically going to
print you know create four five six
trillion dollars of new financial assets
and liabilities that aren't next
Sara Lee supported by anything new there
are even new houses being supported by
all of this so this money is being
created out of thin air and being spent
and financed and it's basically we're
basically just paying people to sit
around and do nothing for the most part
to stay home literally so it's a really
weird environment to think about just
because the you have all these supply
chains that are being cut off and the
basic you know math of like you know any
basic monetarist view of supply and
demand here is that you inevitably there
I don't see how there can't be some
inflation that comes out of this I'm not
you know I'm not like transitioning into
like a hyperinflation sort of mentality
but I don't see how there's any chance
that coming out of like say 2021 or 2022
that if the economy is really rebounding
that we don't have three four five
percent inflation and I think you could
have the Federal Reserve chasing their
own tail raising rates and trying to
catch up with all this stuff way after
the fact